le président de la République est sans
doute donné le thème pot hier soir en
recevant les parlementaires de la
majorité il dit en substance qu'il faut
apaiser écouter la colère des Français
et en même temps
qu'elle soit n'a pas de légitimité de
moi je n'aurais pas dit les choses comme
ça
ces propos méprisants pour la foule
comme il dit qu'il n'a rien à voir avec
le peuple des gentils garçons et gentils
filles qui auraient enlevé leur bonnet
pour le saluer sur son passage on ne
peut accepter
ni les faction ni les factions
la foule est au peuple
ce que le cri est à la voix et bien il
faut que ça rentre en vigueur d'ici à la
fin de l'année mais maintenant au moment
où je vous parle il faut attendre la
décision du Conseil chacun a sa
légitimité
les manifestations ont leur légitimité
mais ça n'est pas une légitimité
supérieure à la légitimité démocratique
est-ce que vous pensez que ça me fait
plaisir de faire cette réforme dites-le
nous non est-ce que vous pensez que
j'aurais pas pu faire comme temps avant
moi mettre la poussière sous le tapis
oui peut-être nous avons entendu des
propos
mécaniques et dilatoires d'un homme
apparemment de plus en plus seul qui
semble avoir perdu tous sens du réel
tout contact avec le monde extérieur y
compris peut-être avec les siens son
intervention du jour est un concentré de
déni de mauvaise foi de provocation et
d'arrogance il y a pas eu de proposition
de compromis donc le compromis il a été
fait par le gouvernement après ses
concertations il a été fait avec
le Parlement mais nous devons avancer il
n'est incapable mais vraiment il est
incapable de se remettre en question il
est incapable d'entendre qu'il a tort il
est incapable d'avoir le moindre geste
alors si il va nous sortir les éléments
de langage qui nous sort à chaque fois
mais entre les sondages et le court
terme et l'intérêt général du pays je
choisis l'intérêt général du pays et
s'il faut derrière endosser
l'impopularité aujourd'hui je
l'endoserai on est en fait chez les
dingue voilà on est avec un président en
fait qui est un pyromane qui est celui
qui verse chaque jour un peu plus
d'essence sur le brasier que la lui-même
allumé il dit ne tranquillement au
restaurant alors que des poubelles
brûlent dehors en marge d'une
manifestation cette vidéo prise lundi
soir dans une pizzeria de Saint-Étienne
fait le tour du monde et du web elle a
pris ses responsabilités avec son
gouvernement et elle a dit au Parlement
si vous avez une majorité alternative
qu'elle s'exprime
lundi il a été montré qu'il n'y avait
pas de majorité alternative
où tout va bien pour ce chien cerné par
les flammes pour beaucoup d'internautes
la France c'est parfaitement approprié
cette scène
madame borne
le vote de confiance
n'est que comme une manifestation
t'attire un programme législatif et un
programme de gouvernement en lien avec
le président de l'Assemblée et la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et
le président du Sénat que j'ai vu hier
pour avoir à la fois moins de textes de
loi des textes plus courts plus clairs
quelle réponse il a écrit va apporter à
la à la crise démocratique dans le pays
aucune tout ce qu'il dit c'est que il y
a une brune pivée qui a rencontré Gérard
Larcher franchement ça nous fait les
pieds le mandat que je vais donner c'est
de continuer à élargir cette majorité
autant qu'elle le pourra avec les femmes
et les hommes de bonne volonté qui de
droite et de gauche ou du côté de
l'écologie à la crise démocratique qu'il
a approfondie à la crise politique qu'il
a ouverte il a répondu par quoi la
perspective de nouveau débauchage sans
doute les députés qui n'ont pas voté la
motion de censure ça c'est une indécence
la droite il n'y a pas vu de main tendue
et même s'il y en avait qu'une nous ne
sommes pas là pour servir de support ou
de roue de secours un pouvoir qui
aujourd'hui dans une impasse c'est
interview c'est du foutage de gueule et
c'est du mépris encore plus fort
vis-à-vis des millions de personnes qui
manifestent et il faut que demain la
réponse elle soit dans la rue les
progrès de l'intelligence artificielle
permettent de créer des images toujours
plus réalistes et d'imaginer
l'impensable le président en première
ligne de la contestation contre la
réforme des retraites voire même
embarquer par des policiers